thanksgiving dass wohl besonders
amerikanische fest wollte ich einmal
erleben allerdings hat man schon
tausendmal gesehen in serie den film in
den medien aber man weiß gar nicht so
richtig was ist das warum feiert man das
und die kurzgeschichte ist denkst gering
ist ein erntedankfest also ganz ähnlich
wie etwas das wir haben ist aber viel
größer denn es bezieht sich auf die
erste ernte die die amerikanischen
siedler nach einem harten winter hatten
als sie amerika besiedelt haben also mit
anderen worten ist das quasi auch so was
wie nationalfeiertag hier und deshalb
wird das so große opulent gefeiert man
kennt die großen truthähne und ich habe
mich gefragt wie ist das wie schmeckt
das wie schmeckt so ein thanksgiving
denn genau das haben wir gemacht genau
das haben wir uns gegönnt wir sind ein
klassisches restaurant gefahren an das
textil menü bestellt viel spaß mit
unserer erfahrung
[Musik]
give thanks giving
also ich hoffe wir haben ein bisschen
lauter musik heran aber wir sind
wirklich in einem sehr hübschen
restaurant paris heißt das ganze wird
von uns überall so gedämmtes licht so
toll und flaschen an elemente aber
trocken
schon sehr lustig wir warten jetzt auf
unseren richtigen platz vielleicht
bringen wir noch was und dann kann die
zinsgewinne experience staat leben
richtig schön wir sehen uns am tisch
angekommen ist es wirklich rundum kraft
die akustik ist quasi links kraft das
ist heftig und freue mich sehr darauf
was uns erwartet so auch kulinarisch
natürlich wir sind ja auch nur gut kenne
hier aber ich bin auch der channel und
das muss jetzt probieren und schmecken
amerikanisches bildung b überraschend
gut versorgen das über das gehalt
gegeben haben nichts mehr auch diese
szenerie hier vorne der weihnachtsbaum
garten kochen ist lagerfeuer und du
sitzt hier im t shirt vor mir im
dezember
schon wirklich außergewöhnlich ist kann
es wir sind in so einem shopping komplex
hier aber finde ich toll aussieht wie
sind luxus komplex sondern überall für
diese lampen und dort schon heftig ok
also erst mal links gewählt heißt ja
erntedank und in deutschland gibt es
auch dass endlich ein festes wird nur
nicht ansatzweise so groß gefeiert habe
ganz ähnlich wie bei endlich haben wir
einen bad hair nach kürbissuppe welt
kürbissuppe immer lecker oder alternativ
ein apfel salat mit getrockneten
kirschen walnüssen und ahornsirup
begriff sehr krass ich meistens was von
beiden nicht nehmen werde aber ich
tendiere ein bisschen eigentlich zur
super dann smoky barrett also
wirklich truthahn ist ja dass
kernbestandteil von brings gelingt und
man kennt das aus den amerikanischen
filmen dieser gigantischen drohten auch
irgendwelche feierlichen tafel und wir
kriegen das glaube ich so von der brust
beschnitten wie gesagt geräucherte
putenbrust mit andy gray wie ist wenn
man so bratensoße dann kartoffelpüree
cranberry marmelade und hausgemachten
brot und zum schluss acht oder extra
aber die werden sich auf jeden fall
lohnt am kind cheesecake
es würden
frühere take the money
dieses stück familie blieb nur aus st
hey wir müssen alles probieren leute
menüs gestellt alle hier am start lara
eric tizi und jetzt gut gehen leute raus
auf unser erstes thanksgiving so dass
jetzt schon ein erster großer
streitpunkt amerikanisches brot ich muss
sagen ist schon krass also im
europäischen raum roth klar dass jetzt
lecker aber in guten restaurants habe
ich schon so krank ist brot gegessen in
deutschland dass das jetzt uns wirklich
nicht weg aber darum geht es heute auch
nicht schauen wir mal was die erste ganz
okay schneller und reden damit die musik
übertüncht wird und dass ich nicht
gestreikt werde wir haben jetzt vor uns
wie butternut kürbis suppe obendrauf
einen schaum von ich weiß nicht genau
was aber ihr seht gerade in der story da
sind auch solche streifen das muss hier
irgendwann mal probieren das hat so eine
sehr dichte konsistenz und es riecht
auch gar nicht wie eine kürbissuppe die
wir kennen auf deutschland ich bin
gespannt ob es geschmacklich in die
richtung geht aber danach habe ich auch
noch nie gegessen
es ist sehr sehr interessant also es ist
überhaupt nicht so eine herzhafte
kürbissuppe wie wir das kennen
vielleicht aus deutschland dieser schaum
oben hauptmission paar chips mit
schnittlauch wird jetzt alles auf
englisch banken veganer ist wirklich
sehr sehr krass es ist irgendwie doch
anders als man es erwartet aber ich
finde das macht lust auf dem mainframe
auf den auf den truthahn auch so einen
deftigen truthahn ich finde auch vom
ersten moment an hat man gemerkt das ist
etwas was man noch nicht hatte der
gewohnten die nase damals hingestellt
haben war direkt so ganz anderer als man
kennt ja das ist wirklich eine so eine
ingwer note man sieht sie auch gerade
aber ohne die schärfe ist gar keine wir
haben uns wir auch einen guten sport
raus und suche preislich weil in zentral
miami und miami beach kostet so einen
gegner so einen gegner schnell 100
dollar plus pro person sondern so
richtig bei 1 45 dollar pro person
übelste also das hier ist sehr sehr
lecker überraschend wenig herzhaft aber
für mich persönlich leitet ist übelst
gut diesen vorteil ein vielleicht kommen
wird spannend vielleicht mal du kennst
es ja gar nicht was würdest du für dich
geben 1 bis 10 uhr für deinen
personaltests 14 bei einer suppe muss
für mich herzhaft sein weil sonst wird
das ist was für ein super erwartet etwas
kräftiges so weißt du das hat das für
mich aber abgesehen davon macht ihr
alles richtig wir hatten richtig geile
so eine sämige konsistenz überlege
zwischen achteinhalb und neun aber
denken wir müssen nochmal können
[Musik]
mendig als erstes kartoffel bewegt
das hat irgendwas eigenes hat irgendwas
neues was ist da noch nicht kennen der
demokrat drin was hat sonos ist wirklich
specials außergewöhnlich ist eine auf ja
ich hab auch eine schärfere china
ist wirklich sehr außergewöhnlich sehr
lecker muskat schärpe viel salz auch
wirklich nur mit kräftige kräftige noten
allein für sich stehen außerdem und
leckeres kartoffelpüree
wir haben 24
der weihnachtsbaum fängt an zu singen
das ist so verrückt grades zu filmen zu
überstehen zu können aber ich gehe jetzt
in die cranberries
also die cranberries habe ich so auch
noch nie gegessen sollte ich lebe nach
beides so noch nie gehabt so truthahn es
wird zeit ich probiere jetzt natürlich
mit brady dazu
ich habe häufig gehört dass es trocken
sein soll ist gar nicht richtig sagt
weck hat irgendwas total leicht ist bin
ganz ehrlich das ist so komplett neu
aber irgendwie vertraut so geschmackvoll
verrückt es ist dass hast du das
weihnachtlich ist irgendwie für mich so
von der anrechnung auf kämpft man denkt
man hat hier so ein baten um gegen
pocket berät aber es ist trotzdem alles
neu aber es ist so nah dass es direkt
gefällt direkt lecker ist also fahrt zum
hauptgang es ist wirklich ein echtes
festmahl und ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass das so opulent ist dass es so viel
ist so ich bin am kämpfen so ich habe
angst vor dem buchen der sogleich kommt
gleichzeitig freue ich mich sehr darauf
aber vor dem feuer ist noch so viel ist
alles gilt übertreiben so ihre lage man
sagt ja immer so dass viele amis so
kräftig sind sieht man hier jetzt
überhaupt nicht so gut aus gesteht aber
anscheinend essen sie zumindest weil das
ist so viel es war auf jeden fall so
dass man es wieder essen möchte und am
liebsten auch wieder in amerika aber das
große fahrzeug kommt natürlich am ende
wir warten jetzt erstmal auf das bisher
banken cheesecake ich habe auch ein
bisschen hofft hecken hey das ist auch
sehr beliebt weiß wert ist dass die tage
außerhalb vom video nochmal aber erstmal
muss ich dazu sagen sieht sehr schön aus
und dem verstehen auf jeden fall was die
machen hier diesem restaurant wir haben
ja so eine karamellsoße wir haben
karamellisierte walnüsse wir haben sahne
glaube ich und wir haben den park inn
cheesecake und ich nehme alles auf einen
löffel und probiere
dass diese feierlichkeit und so dieses
weihnachtliche eigentlich ist eigentlich
alles weihnachtlich das ist das liegt
mir sofern weiß wenn ihr das seht dann
seid ihr alle schon auf
weihnachtsmärkten und so aber wir sind
halt nach florida geflogen ist warm hier
ist schillig sommer aber das hat alles
eher was super weihnachtlich ist und das
hat auch nochmal so diesen festlichen
geschmack alles in allem wirklich
löschen fest na ja das ist es ja auch
das anderen festmahl crazy ist und
gesamtem und ist folgen dieser cache und
bringt so viel mehr mit als ein
einfacher cheesecake es ist von diesen
verschiedenen schichten es ist wirklich
einfach so was krank dieser ganzen
moment ich hoffe und ich würde mich sehr
freuen wenn ihr den nachvollziehen
können wer daran teilhaben können das
würde ich so magisch gerade vorbei das
ist ein skurriles szenario so
weihnachtsbaum lagerfeuer t shirt denkst
greving kuchen es ist ultra krank und
ist alles 10 10 außerdem so wie
es ist insgesamt zehn von zehn erfahrung
auch in holz kamera aber nur sagen dass
es die schönste szenerie in die wir in
der wir bis jetzt trainiert haben bis
jetzt gegessen haben so wir haben
so das ist maximum hier gerade feierte
was danach kommt eine beziehung gleich
gemeinsam unser fazit er ist das jetzt
auf trinkt wie sind wirklich abgrundtief
schlecht ein espresso sondern sehen wir
uns also leute es war wirklich einfach
malerisch ich hoffe ihr habt diese diese
szenerie genau so sehr genießen können
wie ich über das video zwar ein wahres
erlebnis und auch kulinarisch war es
wirklich interessant lecker und habe
mich lange daran erinnern danke dass ihr
zugeschaut habt bis zum nächsten video
wir sehen uns gut